the quantum world is a spooky place
a lot of that spookiness is due to
something called entanglement that's
when two particles become mysteriously
linked when you measure some property
like spin of one particle you
automatically know what the spin of its
partner will be even if that other
particle is on the opposite side of the
universe
weird right let's break it down imagine
each particle is a coin spin those coins
on a table will they land heads or tails
you don't know similarly a particle spin
is a mystery until you measure it now
let's assume these coins become
entangled they're still spinning
finally one lands you see that it's
heads
now you know that the other coin
whenever it lands will be tails
guaranteed the coins or particles aren't
communicating one doesn't call up the
other one and tell it to land tails
instead they're like two parts of a
whole with a shared history and a
mysterious inexplicable cosmic
connection that's the magic of quantum
entanglement physicists have been
exploring how to use entangled particles
to build powerful quantum computers and
unbreakable ciphers but now some
scientists think that such a
long-distance connection has more
fundamental importance
quantum entanglement may serve as the
thread that stitches space together
researchers studying mathematical models
of the universe have found that cutting
the link between previously entangled
particles is like tearing apart the
fabric of space-time
so entanglement a concept Einstein
strongly disliked may actually be the
key to making his general theory of
relativity jive with quantum theory